bien
hola soy pat nicklin soy director de
cámara en la película intensamente y yo
soy adam habib jefe de cámara de la
película intensamente esta elección se
trata de cámaras el arte de usarlas y la
ciencia que las fundamenta primero
hablaremos de cámaras físicas porque las
cámaras virtuales que usamos para
nuestras películas se basan en las
cámaras reales hablemos primero de
objetivos el tipo de objetivo que
ponemos en la cámara y cómo la cantidad
de luz que viajan a través de la lente
afecta la imagen que grabamos sonríe
por ejemplo para esta autofoto usamos un
objetivo gran angular si cambiamos la
lente por una más cerrada y larga como
esta de 75 milímetros la foto se verá
muy diferente
wow increíble apenas salimos en la foto
parece como si hubiéramos movido la
cámara pero no fácil de hecho para tomar
el entorno ya nosotros mismos en esta
foto con esta lente tenemos que mover
mucho la cámara
hola silvia hola nos puedes tomar una
foto seguro chicos estaban tratando de
tomarse una foto con este té el objetivo
tal vez tal vez
qué bueno que tienen una escalera aquí
ahora que ya tomamos la misma foto
puedes ver lo que cambian la imagen
debido a la lente que escogimos por
ejemplo observar que esté enfocado y que
está desenfocado en la imagen con el
objetivo gran angular casi todo está
enfocado y en la foto tomada con el
teleobjetivo sólo una pequeña parte de
la imagen está enfocada otra cosa que
cambia es la sensación de perspectiva de
la imagen
esto significa que tan cerca o lejos
parecen estar los objetos en la toma con
un objetivo gran angular cuando la
cámara está más cerca los objetos más
cercanos parecen mucho más grandes y los
objetos más lejanos parecen estar más
lejos en la toma con teleobjetivo cuando
la cámara está más lejos parece como si
hubiera menos distancia entre los
objetos más cercanos y los más alejados
cualquier decisión que tomes con la
cámara cambiará la sensación de la toma
y nuestro trabajo es tomar decisiones
que resalten la emoción de la historia
mostremos cómo funcionó en intensamente
es la cámara virtual que usamos para
hacer nuestras películas tiene lentes
intercambiables igual que la cámara que
usamos para tomarnos la foto así que
dependiendo de la lente que usemos y la
colocación de la cámara deberíamos ver
un efecto similar en la imagen aquí hay
una toma de intensamente que se parece
mucho en su composición a nuestra foto
empecemos con el mismo objetivo gran
angular que usamos para nuestra primera
foto el de 18 milímetros se ve bien pero
no queremos escoger una lente solo por
lo que podamos meter en el encuadre
tenemos que preguntarnos de qué trata la
escena esta escena trata de la empatía
así que debemos fundamentar con esa idea
todas nuestras decisiones de encuadre
como composición puesta en escena y
selección de lente
creo que intentaré con la lente de 50
milímetros si uso esta lente y ajusto la
profundidad de campo que determina que
está enfocado o desenfocado pienso que
lograremos la toma correcta una imagen
que se centra en los personajes y donde
el fondo se desvanezca hay muchas
sensaciones diferentes que resaltamos
con nuestra selección de cámara
miedo alegría inseguridad asombro en
cada caso pensamos en cómo usar la
cámara para amplificar las emociones que
queríamos lograr en esa escena hay cosas
muy interesantes por aprender así que
quédense con nosotros